mcdonald's coca-cola pepsi start box
símbolos de occidente en rusia
decidieron detener sus operaciones en
dicho país la ex ministra de finanzas de
ucrania dijo a france 24 que el mundo
empresarial tiene una importante
responsabilidad en ese that skin dices
pido a las empresas que se auto
sanciones que apliquen voluntariamente
esos principios ambientales y sociales y
que tomen el camino de irse de dejar de
hacer cualquier negocio en rusia ni
veces más cada parte de cualquier
negocio que hagamos con rusia ahora
mismo está financiando indirectamente la
gestión activa en el sendo guard pero
empresas francesas como yo total energy
y renovado en más en retirarse por sus
fuertes inversiones en el país ya no
tiene 40 mil empleados en sus tres
fábricas rusas y total energy sse tiene
una participación cercana al 20 por
ciento del productor de gas ruso
novatech danón que cuenta con 8 mil
empleados locales y obtiene 6 por ciento
de sus ingresos anuales en rusia afirma
que su retirada no es tan clara
tenemos una responsabilidad con la gente
a la que alimentamos con los
agricultores que nos proporcionan leche
y con las decenas de miles de personas
que dependen de nosotros
hay mucho en juego a nivel financiero
donde
las empresas francesas tienen unos 17
mil millones de euros invertidos en
rusia muchas empresas han invertido
mucho sobre el terreno tiene muchos
activos y retirase significa renunciar a
eso
mientras que manuel marco ha liderado la
presión europea para imponer sanciones a
rusia total energy sse y otros gigantes
corporativos aseguran que el gobierno
francés no los está presionando para que
corten sus lazos incluso cuando la
presión pública sigue creciendo